this week we are celebrating the 50th
anniversary of Apollo 11 in its
monumental achievement landing a man on
the moon the new CBS News poll out just
this morning shows more than seven out
of ten Americans believe the moon
landing was worth it now that's up
nearly thirty percent from four decades
ago and more than 70 percent of
Americans favor sending astronauts back
to the lunar surface CBS evening news
anchor and managing editor that's Nour
O'Donnell spoke with some of the
pioneering women involved in the Apollo
11 mission 50 years ago when the space
program was dominated by men does it
look different yes and no it's much more
pristine poppy Northcutt the only woman
inside of Mission Control was
responsible for calculating the
maneuvers that would bring those
astronauts home you were plotting out
every kind of scenario you always are
thinking about all kinds of
possibilities how nerve-wracking was
that well it's very nerve-wracking it
doesn't matter how successful any other
stage has meant if you don't get them
back safe and sound
back from the moon nor o'donald she is
anchor and managing editor of CBS News
CBS Evening News I got a little chill of
excitement for you Nora when I read that
this morning I'm really really happy
because tonight is your big night the
big night yeah night mm-hmm are you
ready we're ready we're ready you know
and this is an incredible week because
it marks the 50th anniversary the launch
of Apollo 11 an incredible moment not
only for this country but also in CBS
News history because so famously
anchored by Walter Cronkite and the team
did such an incredible job and even
though this was one giant step for
mankind we wanted to go back and look at
the women yeah one of Apollo 11 about
what the environment was like for women
back then well it was a lot of men and
there were a lot of cigarette butts it
was sort of a madman era I mean poppy
Northcutt told me as we went back to to
Mission Control there at Johnson Space
Center I said does it seem different she
goes it smells different a lot better
but I think these are these pioneers
these Trailblazers these women who were
there at the time you know they were
great scientists and mathematicians and
so you'll see each stage they
and what was this massive government
effort there were 400,000 people
involved in that you've got another
story related to this this week an
interview with Jeff Bezos who's a space
entrepreneur as well as running Amazon
obviously do many interviews and with
President Kennedy's daughter Caroline
Kennedy yeah I mean look at this
Caroline Kennedy talked about this being
an example of presidential leadership
this ambitious goal that President
Kennedy sent out is set forward in 1961
to land a man on the moon and Bezos says
in this interview you know people NASA
we're gulping like oh we can do that
within the decade and you know now you
have essentially that's the past
essentially Kennedy this is the future
and now our space program is not really
dominated by the government it's
dominated by billionaires like Bezos and
Maas Elon Musk and aerospace companies
and what's really interesting is that
Jeff Bezos says we have to go back to
the moon in order to save the planet he
talks about something called the great
inversion he's actually been talking
about this since he was 19 years old in
his you know speech when he graduated
from high school essentially we were
going to move he says all major
machinery and industry to moon to the
moon in order to save our planet
it's interesting one of the Apollo
astronauts actually went to the moon or
went toward the moon and came back
saying you know we went to discover the
moon and we actually discovered the
earth because of those amazing pictures
earth rise and the blue marble shot but
let's talk about the future what else
can we expect from the evening news
under your tenure
well it's very exciting tonight is our
debut on the CBS Evening News we've seen
you rehearsing in here like every
morning they have to fix the lights Yeah
right again yeah it's such an incredible
team it's such an incredible team at the
evening news and this is a legacy
broadcast it's actually one of the
longest-running broadcasts indeed it is
you know and Walter Cronkite was known
as the most trusted man in America and I
think we already have the best
journalists here at CBS News and we want
you know fact-based
trusted news every evening and we're
gonna continue to do that and it's
already been happening at the eye on
America series you know the separated
and Counting profiles and service we're
gonna do on the evening news so that
kind of work that double down on
investigative reporting double down on
breaking news well you're here tonight
of course for your debut but tomorrow
you're gonna be down there where Walter
Cronkite was all those years ago yeah I
think about that too nor do you have
goosebumps about this moment I have
goosebumps for you thank you the second
woman to sit in this chair the evening
is yeah it's it's an incredible honor
and I'm excited that we get to take the
broadcast on the road in the first yes
yes we've also got something exciting
planned for Wednesday but stay tuned on
that all right the Kennedy Space Center
I mean in the same location that Walter
Cronkite was when that Saturn 5 lock it
you know blast it off he said go baby go
and it really symbolized for a nation
for the first last time that really this
country was all sitting you imagine the
time when everyone was sitting together
watching the same thing 96 percent of
American households remember very well
in powerful rocket ever built well in
the words of that great philosopher
Grace Tracy also known as your daughter
of course it's like a popsicle mom
cheering you on are always changing
thank you and tonight have you heard you
can watch Nora's debut as an anchor of
the CBS Evening News tonight tomorrow
CBS this morning and the CBS Evening
News will anchor from Kennedy Space
Center in Florida to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of Apollo 11 Tony's going
down right after this show and Nora will
host a prime-time special man on the
moon tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS